[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alex smith
he is the former utah star went to the
49ers
also went to kansas city chiefs
washington football team
had one of the more serious severe
near fatal injuries in football history
and decided to announce his retirement
recently
and alex smith joining us on the program
do you feel like a former player now
you know it's funny because um
you know through the injury i kind of
almost fell into that as well like i
you know i was on the brink of former
football player
uh for a while so i i feel like i've
i've dabbled in this
this this pool before and so yeah it's
not unnatural for me
but also like is your routine the same
like you are you still training working
out how does that work
yeah i honestly i think my routine very
much this time of year is the same
yeah i still i still mix it up i love
enjoying i mean as a quarterback
listen you you know me getting under a
squat rack you know 365 days a year
isn't practical nor does it help me be a
better quarterback so
uh for the last several years i've
enjoyed doing different things in the
off season
as far as training goes and i still do
those things so that part of my life
hasn't changed
i think here as you know as as we creep
towards summer
and fall obviously that's going to be
the true test you know because for
every fall for the last you know
25 plus years of my life uh it's
revolved around football
and uh you know that that obviously uh
is set to change so
um i'm excited for it you know i know
it's not always going to be a
smooth transition but but i look forward
to the unknown and what lays ahead
but is it your mind or your body that
has to be
convinced right now okay oh my my mind
without a doubt my mind my body has
nothing to do with it my body could i i
could still roll i'm in better shape
than i was a year ago i mean i think the
further i i get removed
from uh this injury you know the only
i'm only getting stronger
so my body feels better and better now
but
your body reminds you there's certain
times of the year where you go
i'm supposed to be doing this like late
july or august like what are you going
to be like on a sunday in september
yeah i mean i think that's a great
question i don't i don't know if i'm
you know if i totally know what that's
going to be like you know i
if i'm ready for it and obviously time
will tell when we get there
um i i do think yeah i mean for for a
chunk of my life yeah that
i've always had that release you know to
go to to lace up cleats and get back out
on the field and
um you know push yourself
in that kind of environment and you
can't simulate that anywhere else
you can't get that feeling um that rush
that sensation anywhere else and and so
it is incredibly unique
so we'll see we'll see if uh yeah if i
do miss it i i feel at this point i'm in
a great place i
i you know i've played a ton of football
i'm i'm
i'm looking forward to all the things i
can go do with my family
and my kids things that i've put off for
a long time because of football
when did you have that epiphany that you
went okay i'm good with this
honestly the first the first time i ever
thought it that it first hit me
this this is no joke i was uh i went
um skiing and snowboarding with my kids
and it was something that i'd put off
for a long time because of football
ever since i haven't been since college
and then when the injury happened i
wondered if i doubted if i'd ever be
able to go again
and uh my my dad is
my parents have taken my kids so they're
pretty decent skiers at this point i
haven't ever been with them
you know and i grew up my dad taught me
to ski when i was two years old i grew
up going with my family and it was
always this family environment so i got
to go this year it was amazing it was an
amazing experience
uh for me full of the same range of
motions and the night before i had a ton
of anxiety
couldn't sleep you know wondering about
my leg and how it hold up
and uh and then to get out there with my
kids
and my dad also and and uh for all of us
to be on the mound together and my mom
and you know it was it was an amazing
experience so for me yeah there was a
moment where i
we paused on the side of the mountain
and my two boys were next to me and
my dad was there as well and yeah it
definitely hit me that
i i want more of that you know i i want
to i want to chase more of that i've
been putting that off for a long long
time and
i can go do that now and the reason i
can go do it is partly because i pursued
football
you know that i knew if i pushed
football as hard as i could
all the other things in life i i
wouldn't have any limitations so
i'm excited to go uh to go knock down
some more walls that i've built up
yeah but i thought it was a little
pretentious of you to hold a press
conference on the ski mountain there to
announce that you were retiring
i mean nobody was there but you know you
had your moment had your press
conference
and i thought all along the last month
or so six weeks
that you would join urban and and go to
jacksonville and help
tutor trevor lawrence but i i didn't
know the competitor in you
that wants to start you know like do i
want to be a mentor
and yeah so i wondered how was that how
difficult was that decision
oh i i i think you hit it i i battled
that a lot internally um
that role and i have no problem
obviously mentoring i love it i in fact
you know being a young quarterback
especially a high draft pick and
expectations and
i enjoy talking about the way not to do
it you know for me
how i struggled with those expectations
and and anxiety and you know trying to
get validation every single day and i i
felt like i never allowed myself that
process to grow into that
franchise quarterback i felt like i had
to be that day one and
and put a ton of pressure on myself to
be that and and uh it just mounted and
mounted and it was this
this cycle that was not productive at
all so i enjoy
you know trying to help obviously yeah
other young quarterbacks not go down
that road you know and there's a better
way to do it
and uh but i do struggle with the sense
of
doing it in a role where you're playing
you know and preparing and to be the
starter and to go out there and do that
versus
the back seat that you're really now
you know obviously it's a lot of talk
it's a lot of talk less playing
and so uh struggled if i wanted to do
that
uh what that looked like um so yeah all
those things but
jacksonville definitely was uh same
thing was it was something that was
really interesting to me
um coach meyer and i are still still
close
to this day so you know for the fact
that i'll be close to 20 years down the
line and he's now in the pros
and to think about potentially helping
him build that thing was was exciting to
me but
in the end you know i think all those
other things uh won out
but if somebody offered you a starting
job if washington said hey
would we be having this conversation
would it be a different conversation
yeah oh maybe i mean i think for me i
wanted to see all the
all the options out there i wanted to
see everything that that was on the
table
obviously including retirement and then
make the most informed decision i could
i didn't want to rush anything i wanted
to see
uh everything that was out there and and
yeah so i felt like i did that
and then based off all of those options
you know yeah
at this point i'm moving forward with
retirement you know i don't think you
ever want to never say never but
uh yeah i'm i'm i'm full steam ahead
with that at this point
he's alex smith former football player
you know your one leg got all the
attention
it's your other leg that i'd like to
give some attention to today yeah all
right all right
yeah like it's done a lot of work there
never gets any coverage alex
never and you know and it's it's uh i
still i stole some muscle from it too
my right leg from my from my left so my
left my left's been really uh
you know picking up the slack and it's
been short-handed so
um you know it's amazing what the human
body can do and i remember
when they were explaining to this the
procedure to me in the hospital
and i'm like wait you're going to take
you're going to make my good leg
you're going to make it weaker you know
you're we're going to take one of my
quad muscles and i remember thinking
at that point my left leg was everything
i mean the only way i got around was
jumping around on my left leg
at all and it was and i kept thinking
well we're going to make this weaker
so that i can you know and this one it
might not even work
you know is what they keep telling you
and so it's funny now looking back
they tell you that you're you know your
your left leg will adapt
and you'll be surprised at how strong it
will get
and um they were right funny those
doctors were right it's it's crazy how
uh how the human body uh can adapt
and uh i feel like my left leg is
probably stronger than it was but
before the injury in the operation where
they took my muscle
you remember the last time we had you in
person was in minneapolis
i remember it well and you got traded
five hours later
yeah yep when you came in to do that
interview did you know you were going to
be traded
absolutely without a doubt okay
all right good point
you know basically the trade had been
had
been done nothing had been signed or
anything but they're you know still
working out the details
essentially you know you're you're
signing an extension as well
but yeah that was all basically kind of
in the works and
pretty much done at that point where i i
was with you guys that day
what's it like though when you know and
and you're gonna see matt ryan's
probably gonna see this
uh you know the the veterans see this uh
aaron rodgers is seeing this when all of
a sudden you see the future and you go
we certainly could have used that draft
pick on somebody who could help us this
year
so when the chiefs take patrick mahomes
what did you know you know your days are
numbered
did you feel your days were numbered
um you know i think there were a couple
things yeah i mean
obviously they're taking it we moved up
to take patrick uh
early so i knew you know no question
obviously the future
uh was was in him i think for me i was
going into my 13th year
and i could either let this distract me
from continuing to play good football
play winning football um
you know and certainly there were a lot
of you know media distractions to try to
pit
us against each other or you know i
could choose not to
to buy into that and really not let it
distract me from what i wanted to go do
and continue
down my road towards trying to reach my
potential and play the best
you know football i could play which i
felt like i was still going down that
road so
i i think through everything i've been
through it was really me determined to
not
you know essentially here not let this
become another distraction for me um
and i you know i think thankfully
uh and and proud of the fact that you
know we everybody included in that
patrick you know coach reed the entire
organization chose not to
not let that be what everybody was
trying to make it be you know that it
could be done a different way that that
we could
co-exist did our we weren't pitted
against each other
and so yeah and ended up having probably
one of the best years of my career
maybe the best um in the face of that
and essentially
determined to tell myself that if i
played good football i was i was gonna
have a job
you know and or i could let this
distract me and not play good football
and then it would become this
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah you made
it tough on all the comeback
players of the year that will follow you
because
probably not a lot of them well did you
nearly die
did you nearly lose your leg well alex
smith
did like uh like what did you come back
from you know like
you really made it tough um
you know i think that uh
it's hard i mean football you the crazy
thing is i think there's so much
that goes on that doesn't get seen i
mean obviously this is the
one of the most violent games on on the
planet and
the carnage and you know like the amount
of guys that are up for comeback player
of the year
every single year in the what they go
through behind the scenes to get
back the surgeries uh the toll this game
takes on on the human body
um there's so many guys that deserve
recognition
um certainly obviously what happened
with me was unique
you know in the sense of obviously the
breaking my leg and then the infection
on top of it so um no i mean every all
those
i mean everybody you know there's so
many guys that deserve recognition for
what they put in
uh especially this time of year when no
one's looking
yeah but if they come back from meniscus
tear or something like that
like turf toe come on alex i mean you
know
you made it tough you did you made it
tough for all these other people
how do you look in shorts by the way
does your you know your
legs like you so it's funny it's funny
you ask like yeah
it took me a long time to be able to
wear shorts you know and show my leg it
was
it was a long time before i could even
own that that
that this was me that i wanted that i
was proud of my leg
do you have your shorts it's not it's
not pretty
dan do you have shoes i i don't know i
have pants on
take your pants off right now let me see
what you look like alex
no it's not pretty but uh i am proud of
it you know
and and what it's been through and what
it means to me but yeah it took me a
long time before i could i could show it
off and flaunt it
uh you know and that that i could own it
yeah um thank you
uh it's been great watching you from uh
from you know the days in utah to where
you are today and uh you know you get to
spend time with your family and
i i think although i want to know what
it's like you know because when i left
espn i went home
and i didn't have a job for uh six
months and you know i was gonna spend
time with the kids
and i got home for about two weeks and i
went oh my god
what am i doing here so you might have i
think you're right
i think you're right i mean and i'm not
planning i don't you can't do nothing
you know i can't do nothing so i got to
find something but i think uh
you know what it is can i can i find a
balance you know
good luck alex thank you for joining us
thank you dan appreciate it
that's alex smith maybe they named the
comeback player of the year award the
alex smith award
just throwing that out there